now
okay so we de-energized uh the mount
charleston area at approximately 6 45
this morning that was based off of a
concern that the storm system that's
moving through the spring mountains
is bringing with it elevated winds we
were seeing winds in the kyle canyon
area
of about 65 miles an hour and up on the
angel peak area where a lot of the lines
that feed into mount charleston are we
were seeing
wind gusts in excess of 75 miles an hour
so at those elevated wind speeds
we definitely meet our psom criteria for
proactive de-energization and so that's
why we de-energized the mountain this
morning we've been tracking this weather
system for the past several days
uh in the past 36 hours we really saw a
change in the weather forecast an
increase in the forecasted wind gusts
specifically
and so that's why yesterday we declared
a psalm warning
once we realized that that forecast was
starting to change for the worse
specifically with the wind gusts
so right now we are de-energized
we expect wind gusts to peak somewhere
between 1 pm and 5 p.m today
and then depending on when those wind
gusts start to subside we will start the
re-energization of the mountain
prior to re-energization we have to
conduct a patrol
on
all of our facilities up in the mount
charleston area so if the winds do not
subside by say five or six tonight we
will have to keep the power off
overnight at mount charleston because we
have to conduct those inspections during
daylight hours one so that we can
actually see the facilities but two
to ensure the safety of our crews so we
have a full team up there right now that
continues to monitor the weather real
time and as soon as this weather event
subsides we will begin that proactive
re-energization process either tonight
if
if
the weather allows or tomorrow morning